so Comic Con happened recently and that
means that a whole bunch of awesome
stuff happened that I didn't get to see
in person but thankfully there are a
whole bunch of law breakers out there
who bring out their cell phones whenever
something amazing happens and so I got
to see the leaked version of the Comic
Con trailer for Batman V Superman dawn
of Justice extremely long title
hopefully an awesome movie
that video is everywhere that actually
have the footage are getting pulled down
left and right because no one wants free
promotion so for that reason I'm not
going to show you any of the footage but
I'm going to tell you about what's in
this thing and I am truly excited for
this movie I was already depressed the
thing is getting pushed back to 2016 and
now that I've seen this thing I'm
devastated you see Ben Affleck as Batman
in the armored suit he strikes on the
bat-signal which shines upon Superman
whose eyes glow red with fire we zoom in
on Batman's face his eyes are glowing
whitish blue and I became a man just
that brief little moment of footage
tells me one important thing they're
doing their best to actually respect the
look of the source material this new
film has a different writer for Man of
Steel which I thought was the weakest
aspect of Man of Steel the writing the
story this should be much more improved
that comes from the writer of Argo we
have a talent like Ben Affleck involved
who has shown himself to be a creative
force of nature I am extremely excited
for this movie I have a good feeling
about this one and not just because I
want to I really think this movie is
going to be good also this is the first
time we're going to see a Batman moment
in a live-action film where his eyes are
white because that's the way he looks in
the majority of the comics I do like how
in a live action film you can see the
actors eyes because that is something
that allows you to get more emotionally
invested in him as a character I
understand that that has to be that way
I like that however it is really cool
they found a way to include the white
eyes and make it make sense I am so
pumped out of my mind for this movie
that I don't even want to talk about it
anymore because it doesn't come out to
2016 and it's still 2014 so I don't
really want to keep hyping myself
because I'll just it's not healthy what
are your thoughts on this footage I'm
always curious to hear what you guys
have to
say thank you so much for watching and
as always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck Minh eyes
[Music]